none of the Intelligence Officers I've
ever met sorry about this by the way U
none of you look like the James Bond
type they're not super human uh they're
just odly people conducting a job that
in this case keeps the UK safe James
Bond does some incredible stuff I don't
think we can compete I would say that we
don't have any real James Bonds in our
organization
[Music]
sadly there were three kinds of
intelligence agency in the United
Kingdom MI6 is mostly concerned with
threats from abroad MI5 is mostly
concerned with domestic threats and gchq
does a lot of intelligence gathering
around signals intelligence
telecommunications and satellite
surveillance the intelligence services
are facing numerous threats over the
years from the second world war when
it's Gathering Intelligence on Nazi
Germany the Cold War when we return yet
again to monitoring Soviet threat
terrorism the rise of China
[Music]
Russia historically recruitment was very
opaque there is the traditional idea of
a tap on a shoulder at University
usually Oxbridge during the second world
war women proved their metal in terms of
being excellent spies but in the
aftermath of the second world war the
agencies went back to recruiting mostly
male mostly uh people from a particular
Elite background it wasn't until 1973
that the marriage ban was lifted before
then uh women had to leave the secret
intelligence service if they wanted to
marry more recently uh the chief of MI6
sis Richard Moore actually issued an
apology on behalf of his service on the
attitudes towards lgbtq plus individuals
within his Organization for the
preceding 40 50
years my name is Joe and I work for gchq
the government Communications
Headquarters diversity is really really
important to us at gchq our work
involves tackling some really kind of
complex naughty problems and in order to
be successful at our mission we need a
real mix of Minds so we need people from
different backgrounds who've had
different life
experiences um to come and work with us
today recruitments actually changed
quite a lot you can go on MI5 mi6's
website and applied direct to the
intelligence agencies I think definitely
the tap on the shoulder is is not
something that happens these days um
it's really very different I work as an
intelligence analyst in gchq I've been
working there for five years I heard
about this role on a recruitment website
I wasn't sure if it was what it was
really about because the subscription
was quite limited but I knew I always
wanted to work in the public sector so I
thought I'd give it a go and just
[Music]
applied there isn't one type of person
that the intelligence agencies are
looking for you couldn't have the kind
of cold-hearted misogynistic loner that
James Bond represents in the
intelligence agencies today because they
wouldn't be able to function as part of
a team the one overriding characteristic
you need as an intelligence officer
is discretion you can't have people
blabbing about what they do in the pub
or to their friends because that is a
security threat we're really looking for
people who can work as a team we want
people who um are thoughtful are kind
and considerate care about the people
they're working with and also care about
doing the right thing and keeping the
country safe I think being patient is
really important for our job sometimes
it's really difficult to have all the
answers I think it's really important as
well to be a bit creative with your
Solutions sometimes we have a lot of
data so it's good to be able to think of
unique and creative ways to look at that
data some of the obstacles for us are
the the stereotypes that are out there
in the James Bond films and um other
fiction around um what spies are like
and what people working for our
organizations look like and and how they
behave I was definitely aware of the Spy
stereotypes in terms of UK government
security and I was a bit nervous with
that I think I was more nervous of
particularly not fitting in maybe being
a female from a certain background
sticking out like a sore
[Music]
thumb well they may not be as handsome
as Daniel Craig or Shan connory but
still the majority of people who are
recruited into the agencies are male the
agencies have varied in terms of how
they've been able to put diversity into
practice MI5 the security service was
the first one to have a female lead gchq
has also now had a female lead appointed
to the agency MI6 as of 2023 hasn't yet
had a female leader of the
[Music]
organization in 2018 the UK's
intelligence and security committee
released a report that looked at
involvement from black e minority
background groups within the
intelligence Community around 7 8% of
the workforce come from these
underrepresented groups and in all areas
there was much room for
improvement we talk about diversity as
being Mission critical in gchq and
that's because we have to solve some
really difficult complex problems um and
in order to do that we need people who
think differently from one another we
need people who will come at problems
from a different angle the intelligence
agencies are recruiting from diverse
backgrounds because operationally it's
important you need an intelligence
officer who might understand the culture
and the environment they're going to be
operating again I definitely feel like I
really fit in it's a really inclusive
environment and it's really friendly and
supportive so I would genuinely say to
anyone who is thinking about it to
definitely give it a
go thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video